does this image don't worry about if it
means anything to you but does this
image ring
any bells whatsoever it rings bells okay
good
what you're looking at here is um
and i'll scroll a little further down
because you can't see the whole thing
sorry about that
what you're looking at here is a typical
superannuation situation yeah
stay with me 12. i know it's the end of
the day typical superannuation
situation in that um we've got regular
installments
going in and each year interest also
gets calculated so
which part of the graph or which parts
of the graph are the regular
installments can you remind me
yep fantastic it's those little vertical
intervals right and that's why you can
see
it's the same vertical jump every time
because i'm putting in the same
installment
every time okay so that's good and then
you've got these bits joining
the vertical lines these kind of slanty
bits and they get more and more slanty
as you go what are those
interest calculations perfect so that's
why they get
steeper as you go along because you've
got more money in the bank or in the
superannuation fund
so you get more interest okay so very
good we have this situation here okay
now you may recall
you can even see it there on the left
especially when you've got a situation
like this where you're like many many
years right
we use the sum of a gp the sum of a
geometric progression to be able to work
out
this figure up here future value right
and within the scope of the course we
can operate
all of the machinery to do that
like that formula over there it might
take some remembering but we can do it
okay it's part of series and sequences
but number one
we don't want to always have to go to
doing this by hand right
number one number two we don't even
necessarily want to do this
with a spreadsheet which is what we
looked at a couple days back right
this is such a common situation that in
fact
all kinds of ordinary people who don't
understand the mathematics underneath
this
want to be able to interact with this
and that's why
we hand them tables okay now a future
value table
i'll show you one those of you who
managed to download it successfully
will have this guy here on the first
page
of your pdf so if you have it there open
it up but if you don't have it there yet
do not spend time finding it you'll be
able to see this the whole time i'm not
going to take it away okay
i'll show you later okay if you haven't
got it yet like i said we'll catch up
but what you're looking at here is a
future value table
what does it tell you if you were to
invest a dollar
just one at a certain interest rate you
can see them
across the top uh these are the
different columns at different interest
rates
for different amounts of time that's the
different rows
okay if you invested a dollar how much
would that dollar
be worth okay so let's just give a quick
example right if i invested a dollar
at a four percent interest per annum so
you can see which column i'm on the four
percent one right
and if i invested that for say six years
and remember this is uh this is a
superannuation annuity situation
so it's not just a dollar and that's it
i keep on putting
extra dollars in each year right that's
my installment
if i did this for six years what would i
end up with what would the future value
of that installment be and the answer is
you can read down to the correct column
in row
it'd be worth six dollars and 63 cents
okay now hopefully that at least like
roughly makes sense to you because
you're like if i was doing it for six
years
i at least put six individual dollars in
there
and then the 63 cents is what
this is this is the interest rate that's
the whole point of putting money into
this okay
so this kind of table can be used you
can see you don't need to know anything
about geometric progressions to be able
to say oh
this amount of money for this long at
this interest rate i'm just going to
look at the table
okay but we do know all that stuff
with geometry progression so that's why
we're going to answer these two
questions number one where these numbers
come from they're just like
out of thin air like 6.633 says who
right and then once we know where they
come from because we have that knowledge
where they're going to say okay well how
do we then use these tables right
so let's have a go at this and that
example that i just gave you before
let's start by writing that one down
let's try and get at
where this number comes from 6.633
so as an example we are considering
a one dollar annuity
so remember what that means a dollar is
going in at regular installments
um what do we say four percent interest
per annum
now by the way you might notice there's
no mention of
per annum or years or anything like that
on this table
because i could just as easily use this
to say what if i had eight percent
interest
per annum but i compounded
bi-annually that right biannual buy any
orders once every two years
biannual is twice in a year okay so if i
had eight percent per interest
and i did it twice in a year each chunk
would be
four percent do you agree with that so
i'm just thinking about it in simple
terms but
we can multi-purposely use this table
okay question
oh okay sure yeah do you remember the
whole idea we can take an interest rate
and we can compound
at different frequencies right we could
compound daily
monthly whatever biannually would be to
do it
twice in a year right so an eight
percent interest rate
done twice or each component like the
first half of the year you get four
percent
and the second half of the year you get
four percent a game okay
uh what time period did we say i think
we said six years right should we go
with that
six years okay now
big important thing to state because
every table does this slightly
differently so if you have another color
please get it out because we're going to
write something super important
uh the installment and put this in red
the installments for this table okay
installments happen at the end of a year
installments happen
the end of the year now
as we form the geometry progression that
will land us on these numbers
as we've seen before whether the
installment happens at the start or at
the end
kind of makes a big difference it'll
throw your numbers out if you don't
recognize this okay
it's a bit sneaky this table on its own
right doesn't provide you this context
the document you've downloaded does
actually say that in the paragraph above
but i'm highlighting it now for you okay
so here's our mission we want to try and
get at that number
how do we do this well what i'm going to
say is i'm going to start off by
letting let's just get some pronumerals
in here so we can work with this
situation
so let's let a n
be the amount that's in the
superannuation fund in the annuity
um the amount or i should say the the
total amount
at the end of n years right so a1 would
be at the end of the first
year a2 at the end of the second year
and so on so let's let a
n equal the total amount at the end
of the nth year
okay so this will be our model therefore
we can say what a
one is by definition okay so this is
just at the end of the first year
what has happened in the course of this
12 months
if i go back to the image this will
hopefully help you this graph here
right you can actually see it there at
the end of the first year um
what's happened
yeah the money's just gone in right
because my installment
went in at the end of that year right so
i get this one
dollar massive installment right uh
nothing's happened to it it hasn't been
there long enough to accrue interest
does that make sense
so i'm calling it the first first year
um it's true i could define it as
like a0 or a1 etc whatever makes most
sense to me
i'm just calling the first year year one
okay
um that's it you know because it
happened at the end no interest
i'm done which corresponds to that
horizontal line at the bottom and then
it just goes up
and that's it okay coming back to this
so we can refer to it
that's a1 a2 all right
so what happens in this second year
same deal right two things happen uh
there's going to be
interest and then there's going to be an
installment which one happens
first
the interest happens first because as
stated the installment is the very last
thing to happen
okay so we're going to start with this
which is a dollar
and then we apply our interest to that
um how do i do that
i multiply by 1.04 okay so let's just
pop that in 1.04
interest has happened and then the
second thing is
another dollar comes in there's our
second installment
okay we've done a1 we've done a2 we only
need one more to establish the pattern
so a three will equal
uh the two things happen again and they
happen in the same order every time
okay so this is that recursive id that
we mentioned on monday
okay everything you can see here
gets interest applied to it is that okay
so let's go through and do it one at a
time here's the first one
that's what it was before and now i plop
another
calculation of interest onto it so it's
now squared so far so good
yep here comes the next one
this is all last year's money remember
it gets its interest
and then final piece of the puzzle the
end of the year arrives
and we add a third installment because
we're in the third year okay